Kimberly: Well, this
place is an insane mess!
Allison: This is
all my game fuel.
I have no time for trash.
Kimberly: It’s not trash!
This is all recyclable!
Anyway, aren’t you supposed
to be working on homework?
Allison: Homework!
I don’t have time for that
monotonous, repetitive work.
I am almost level 40 on
World of Plasticracft!
I just have to collect 3 more
water bottles with the number 2
imprinted on them, take them to
the high elvish recyclomancer
and then I’ll be able to cast
malleability 3 times per day
on any random
encounters below level 5.
These are important things!
Kimberly: I stopped listening
after you said “World”.
Allison: this game has
educational garbage
I never pay attention to, you
can probably help with that.
Log on to Mom’s computer.
Kimberly: I cannot believe
you’ve talked me into
this nerd stuff…
Password... Y-E-S. Enter.
Oh, Gosh.
Well, this is magical!
WAH!
Allison: Welcome to Plasteroth!
Kimberly: This place is a dump!
Don’t you guys ever recycle?
Allison: Recycle?!
Are you kidding?!
When you’re adventuring and
your bag of holding gets full,
you just gotta drop that item.
Kimberly: But these
are all plastic!
Many of these can
easily be recycled!
Blort: Back for more,
little orc?!
Allison: Not again!
Kimberly: Who is this?
Allison: He’s Blort
the Corpulent.
I can’t prove it yet,
but I think he’s 32 and
lives in his mom’s basement.
Blort: Wrong!
28 and my aunt’s attic!
Have at thee!
Kimberly: Ah, gross!
Where are we?
Allison: Blort got us.
we re-spawned in the graveyard.
Pollymer: Haldo, travelers!
It would appear
to mine eyes that
thou art experiencing
difficulties.
Allison: Who are you?
Pollymer: Greetings and
salutations,
I am Lady Polly of Mer and I...
Ok, I can’t do that anymore.
I’m Pollymer.
If you want to beat Blort, you
need to learn how to recycle.
Follow me.
Kimberly: Told you so!
Allison: This game had better
not be tricking me into
being a better person!
Pollymer: In Plasteroth, all of
our items and loot are made of
plastics, but the best players
don’t throw out old loot,
they recycle their
unwanted items.
Allison: Ok, fine.
Let’s gather this junk up and
throw it in the recycling bin.
Kimberly: You can’t do that!
All these plastics
are different!
Allison: Plastic is plastic.
Pollymer: Your sister is right.
Kimberly: Again.
Pollymer: Haven’t you ever
noticed those numbers on
the bottom of items?
Allison: I always assumed
those were stats that only
uber nerds paid attention to.
Pollymer: you are not wrong,
but those numbers also tell you
the kind of plastic
that item is made of.
There are 7 basic
types of plastic.
You can usually find the number
in a triangle shaped recycling
symbol on the bottom
of the product.
These numbers are the resin
identification code.
The code is used internationally
and tells us whether we can
recycle the plastic or not.
Plastics are made of sheets of
long chemicals Called polymers.
Different plastics are
made of different polymers.
Between those sheets are
plasticizer chemicals that
give plastics their properties.
These chemicals can make
plastics harder, softer,
smooth, or flexible.
There’s a lot going on in there.
Plastics 1 and 2 are the
most commonly recycled
types of plastic.
Most types of bottles are
made using plastics 1 and 2.
Allison: So types 1 and 2
can be recycled anywhere?
Pollymer: Probably,
but you have to check.
Plastics 4, 5, and 6 are
the next most recycled.
These plastics are very
common in food wraps,
Straws and styrofoam that
people usually throw out.
These plastics can be
tricky to recycle, and
not all areas accept them.
Allison: didn’t you skip one?
Pollymer: Yeah, number 3.
These plastics are
made with vinyl, and
they are rarely recycled.
There’s just not much demand
for plastic 3 as a recyclable.
Kimberly: weren’t there
7 types of plastic?
Pollymer: Correct!
If the plastic doesn’t fit
into the other groups, or
it’s made of a mixture
of plastics, it’s a 7.
This plastic has become
controversial because
they often include a
chemical known as BPA,
which comes with health
Concerns if ingested.
Because this plastic is so
inconsistent, not many
recycling programs
take plastic 7...
In Plasteroth, few master
the magics of recycling.
Legend tells of a warrior
that can wield a blade
made of all the
elemental plastics,
Recy’klar, destroyer of wastes.
Allison: Epic loot?!
Let’s sort this plastic!
Kimberly: Well, that depends
what plastics can be taken in
Plasteroth’s recycling program.
Allison: You mean they
don’t just take it all?
Pollymer: not in all areas.
Every area of the country takes
different plastic numbers
in their recycling.
So while plastics 1,2,3,4,5 and
7 may be recyclable In
Sheboygan, Wisconsin,
they may not take Plastic 7
in Pittsburg, Pennsylvania.
Joey-the-recycling guy: Hey,
What I tell yinz kids about
puttin’ plastic 7
in a recyclin’?
Aww, they’ll throw
that whole bin awt.
Pollymer: Even if your area
doesn’t take some plastics,
many grocery stores will
recycle your plastic bags, and
electronic stores often
recycle disks and old devices.
With some effort, very little
should be going to the landfill.
Fortunately, here in Plasteroth,
we take all seven plastics.
Allison: all in the same bin?
Pollymer: Uh huh
Allison: DIDN’T
I SAY THAT LIKE THREE
EXPOSITION HEAVY
LECTURES AGO?!
Kimberly: Yeah,
but now you know why!
Pollymer: Come on,
Let’s take this plastic
to the recycling forge.
Allison: I can’t believe
Kimberly managed to
ruin video games!
This is him?!
I thought elves were,
like… attractive…
with bows and arrows…
Kimberly: and less burgers.
Pollymer: Just like
America, fewer than 30% of
Plasteroth players
use recycling forges.
There is demand
for the material,
but not enough
people bother.
HALDO SMITHY!
Smithy: Goodness!
Who goes there?
Kimberly: Three adventurers
seeking your services… Sir.
Smithy: I used to
be an adventurer.
Then I took a high density
polyethylene arrow to the knee.
Pollymer: We have brought
the 7 elemental plastics.
We seek to forge Recy’klar,
Destroyer of Wastes!
Smithy: So, you seek the
blade of heroes, eh?
Best get to it then.
The first thing you have to know
about plastic recycling is that
you rarely make the
same thing twice.
If you bring me a soda bottle, I
can’t recycle the materials into
a new soda bottle, the
material’s different.
When I get plastics, I
have to sort them by type.
I can’t mix type 1 plastics
with type 5 plastics.
Then we grind the
plastic into chips.
All of the labels and bits of
glue are in the way at this
point, so we will need to
wash and bathe the chips.
After they dry, we melt
the chips into pellets.
These pellets can be
used to make new items.
Most recycled plastics can
become polar fleece,
tote bags, containers,
furniture, insulation,
brushes, lots of things!
But today in my
forge, we’ve made…
Recy’klar! Destroyer of Wastes!
Mike: Please, Blort, don’t send
me back to the graveyard!
Blort: This validates
me as a person!
Hahaha!!
All too easy…
Allison: Stand down, Blort!
Blort: Back again, young maiden?
Allison: Behold Recy’klar!
Destroyer of Wastes!
Your days of looting
and polluting are done!
Hah!
A recycled blade?
The only way to win in this
world is to buy the newest,
nicest loot.
Pollymer: That’s not going
to work forever, Blort!
We only have so many
raw materials to make
new plastics on this planet!
And where do we
put all the waste?
This stuff just sits
in a landfill forever.
We don’t know how long plastics
last, and some of them release
harmful chemicals into our
bodies and the environment.
Blort: Enough talk!
Allison: I agree!
Blort: Whatever, my aunt’s
calling me for dinner anyway.
Kimberly: Well, I have to say,
Allison, I actually learned
a lot from that game.
Our world doesn’t have
infinite resources.
We need to care about recycling.
It’s important to check the
numbers on our plastics so
you can make sure that you’re
recycling the right materials.
So, Allison, are you going
to recycle all this junk?
Allison: What?
You expect me to apply a lesson
from a game to real life?
Kimberly: Recycle it!!!
Auntie: Blart, come to dinner!
Blart: But people are wrong on the Internet!!
Auntie: Now!
Blart: Yes, Auntie.